NOW IN SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHABAS NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRO.
BURKE.
GABRIELLE.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
SO BONTA AS.
CHAO.
CHAVEZ.
GEN TO.
CHAUDHRY.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
PHONE.
FRASER.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER IN A GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SOLACE
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE.
BERMAN.
TING.
POPO.
WALDRON.
WEBER MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
WE ARE GOING TO GO IN HAVE A
BRIEF RECESS FOR REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS.
THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS WHAT'S THE REPUBLICANS
TO PLEASE JOIN THEIR COLLEAGUES
FOR CAUCUS THANK YOU
FAMILY IS BACK IN SESSION
MEMBERS PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY TO
THE FLOOR
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
TODAY'S A VOCATION. WHICH WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
EVERY HOSTED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
ALTHOUGH THE WEATHER ME INDICATE
OTHERWISE.
WE ARE NOW OFFICIALLY INTO THIS
SPRING SEASON OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
DRIVING THROUGH THE REASON
RECENT DOWNPOURS. I WAS REMINDED
OF A CONVERSATION DOCTOR
TAKEMOTO SHIITE IRAQI.
HAD WITH A CAB DRIVER DURING THE
RAINY SEASON IN KYOTO.
AS DOCTOR SHE GOT LUCKY ENTERED
THE CAB. RATHER THAN COMPLAIN
ABOUT THE RAIN AS MANY WERE. HE
COMMENTED TO THE CAB DRIVER THAT
THIS RAIN WOULD CLEAN THE AIR
POLLUTION AND SMOG.
AND THE DAYS AFTER THE RAIN
WOULD BE BEAUTIFUL.
TWO DOCTORS YOU IRAQI SURPRISE.
THE CAB DRIVER REPLIED.
YOU KNOW. WE HUMANS ARE THE SAME
WAY.
UNLESS WE SHED TEARS
OCCASIONALLY WE ARE UNABLE TO
SEE LIFE CLEARLY.
DOCTOR SHE GOT LUCKY WAS MOVED
BY THE CAB DRIVERS DEEPLY
THOUGHTFUL RESPONSE.
IN LIVING LIFE.
IT IS INEVITABLE THAT WE WILL
EXPERIENCE TIMES OF GREAT JOY.
AND DEEP SORROW.
ARE TEARS OF GREAT JOY AND OUR
TEARS OF SADNESS.
ARE THE MOST MEANINGFUL.
THEY MARK MOMENTS IN OUR LIVES
YOU WILL NEVER FORGET.
FOR THEY ARE ARE TEARS OF LOVE.
WHEN AYE DRIVE IN THE RAIN I
OFTEN REFLECT ON THE TEARS OF
LOVE. THAT HAVE MARKED THE MOST
MEANINGFUL MOMENTS OF MY LIFE.
EACH HERE HELPING ME TO SEE LIFE
MORE CLEARLY.
REMINDING ME TO BE GRATEFUL FOR
ALL THE LOVE THAT IS ENRICHED MY
LIFE.
AND THEN MANY KINDNESSES THAT
HELPED ME TO THE MOST DIFFICULT
OF TIMES.
WHEN OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN.
EVEN THE RAIN CAN REMIND US
WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT. IN
LIVING EACH DAY.
NUMBER ONE.
BUT KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
I AM BY YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR TODAY'S FLAG SALUTE TO WHAT
WILL BE LED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARK STONE.
MEMBERS AND VISITORS.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREFABRICATED
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
FOURTEENTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE SEMANTICS CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS ABOUT
IS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING NOW TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS
TODAY'S ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND.
RECORDED IN TODAY'S JOURNAL.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO TO HAVE
GUESTS.
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS.
SPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND I WAS IN THE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GIPSON AND
RUBIO TO SPEAK ON IN GERMANY.
TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
EXCUSE ME AT THE REQUEST OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR PLEASE RETURN AB
SIXTEEN NINETY ONE BY THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SENATE FOR FURTHER ACTION
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
TO WITHDRAW AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FOUR DAVID CHIU FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO AND RE
REFER THE BILL TO THE PRIVACY
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
AND THEN BACK TO LOCAL GOT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
RE REFER ITEM TWENTY HR TWENTY
SEVEN LOW TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
THE RESOLUTION WAS MISTAKENLY
REPORTED TO THE FLOOR WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER TO
TAKE UP HR EIGHTY NINE WITHOUT
REFERENCE.
MANY OR FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.MISTER
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE TO
IT'S WHAT'S FROM MY DISTRICT.
THEY REPRESENT NEW HOPE CHURCH
OF CONCORD PASTORS JOE AND TINA
SKILES ARE HERE WITH MEMBERS AND
OTHER PASTORS
THE CONGREGATION.
JOINING THEM TODAY ARE COURTNEY
IN MESA SKILES ROBERT BRENDA AND
BEEN BOUGHT AND SHARON SHAUNA
BOB.
AND BLAIR BALK AND MIGHT ALISON
ATTY POPE AND TIGHTEN SMALL
WOULD.
NEW HOPE SERVES THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY BY OFFERING A VARIETY
OF PROGRAMS AND
TIFFANY.
AND THESE ACTIVITIES
CLUED NEW HOPE ACADEMY A PROJECT
BASED LEARNING SCHOOL SERVING
PRESCHOOL THROUGH FIFTH GRADE.
MORNINGSTAR MORNINGSTAR OUT
REACH A SUMMER CAMP FOR
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS. GRATEFUL
GATHERINGS ARE NOT PROFITABLE
FURNISH HOMES FOR FAMILIES
TRANSITIONING OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS OR CRISIS LEVEL UP
SPORTS ACADEMY YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM USING BASKETBALL. STREET
RAYMOND SOCIETY A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION TO HELP SINGLE
MOTHERS AND LASTLY QUEST ACADEMY
A LEADERSHIP TRAINING PROGRAM
FOR KIDS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING MY CONSTITUENTS TO THE
CAPITAL TO THEIR CAPITAL.
WE.
THANK YOU.
SOME OF THEM ARE CALDERON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
UNDER.
MOTION.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER TO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
A. B. NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
WALDRON FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE IN AB TWENTY
FOUR ELEVEN MCCARTY FROM THE
COUNT ABILITY ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW COMMITTEE. TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
HR EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
PLEASE READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER FRAZIER RELATIVES
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AWARENESS MONTH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT HR EIGHTY NINE. WHICH
RECOGNIZES MARCH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AS NATURAL NATIONAL
DEVELOPMENTAL MEDICINE HOLDING
ON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
PAULA JONES REP I INTERRUPTED MY
COLLEAGUE BUT MEMBERS IT IS
EXTREMELY LOUD IN THE FLORIDA
COMPLETES GIVE OUR ATTENTION
RESPECT TO THE MEMBER.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR POINT WELL
TAKEN PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU TO OUR MAJORITY
LEADER.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT HR
EIGHTY NINE WHICH RECOGNIZES
MARCH TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS
NATIONAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AWARENESS MONTH.
THE LATTER MEN ACT STATES THAT
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
HAVE A RIGHT.
TO GET THE SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO LIVE LIKE PEOPLE
WITHOUT DISABILITIES.
COLLEAGUES.
LET'S TAKE THE TIME TO DATE TO
COMMAND THE ADVOCATES
PERSISTENTLY FIGHTING TO KEEP US
IN LINE WITH THE LANHAM ACT.
RAIN OR SHINE DURING TIMES OF
RECESSION OR TIMES A SURPLUS.
LEADERS OF THE COMMUNITY ARE OUT
AT OUR DOORS REMINDING US THAT
THERE IS STILL WORK.
NEEDING TO BE DONE.
BEARS LIKE LACK OF HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS TO
RESOURCES. BUDGET CUTS IMPEDE
INDIVIDUALS FROM ACCOMPLISHING
THEIR GOALS AND PARENTS HAVE
ATTENDED THE SAME WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN TO MY CHILD.
AFTER I'M GONE.
THAT IS NOT FAIR TO A PARENT TO
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT. GOING
FORWARD.
SUPPORTING THIS COMMUNITY IS A
PERSONAL PASSION OF MINE AND I
WANT TO MITIGATE OBSTACLES AND
HELP THESE FOLKS GET WHAT THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
I AM PROUD OF THE ASSEMBLY FOR
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS COMMUNITY BY ALLOWING THE
FORMATION OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE ARE
HARNESSING OUR RESOURCES TO
ASSIST ADVOCATES OF THE
COMMUNITY AS BEST WE CAN.
OFTENTIMES IT WOULD SEEM THAT
THEY ARE FIGHTING THE BATTLE FOR
INCREASE SUPPORT. ON THEIR OWN
AND THAT'S NOT FAIR.
LET'S LET THEM KNOW THAT THEY
ARE NOT ALONE PLEASE.
HR YOU NINE IS WRITTEN TO
COMMEMORATE THIS YEAR'S THING
SEEMING.
FORMING.
WELL.
WE DO SEE YOU.
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE SEEING
NEW.
WE VALUE AND CONTENT AND WE WANT
TO CONTINUE OUR PARTNERSHIP.
I LOOK FORWARD TO ALL THE GREAT
WORK WE WILL DO TOGETHER.
AND IT WOULD LIKE TO PERSONALLY
THANK THE INDIVIDUALS ARE AND
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO INCREASE.
THE AWARENESS OF DEL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THEY'RE
SUPPORTING RECOGNIZING. THE FULL
RANGE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS. AND
CAPABILITIES THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE.
BETTER SPEAKER MAY I GO TO VIEW
OF MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK TO
ANNOUNCE MY GUESS WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
COLLEAGUES IF I CAN DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE GALLERY.
TECHNICALITY.
OKAY.
WE'LL HOLD ON THE GAS
INTRODUCTIONS UNTIL UP THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED SOME
MEMBER LACKEY ARE RECOGNIZED.
YEAH I JUST REAL QUICKLY AND
VERY THANKFUL FOR MY COLLEAGUE
FOR BRINGING THIS.
.
THIS ISSUE TO THE FLOOR I ME IS
YOU NOT A FAN OF OF WORKED
ISSUES.
BUT I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR THIS
ONE.
BECAUSE I I HAVE TO TELL YOU
THAT.
.
THIS PART OF OUR CULTURE.
HAS COME ALONG WAY IN OUR
CULTURES COME ALONG WAY IN
TRYING TO ADAPT IN A BRACE.
THE FOLKS THAT FACE THESE.
ENORMOUS CHALLENGES EVERY DAY
THE THINGS WE TAKE FOR GRANTED
EVERY DAY ARE.
OUR HUGE ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR
MANY OF THEM.
BUT YET.
THIS LEGISLATURE I COME TO FIND.
HAS.
DONE VERY VERY LITTLE THE
MINIMAL.
BARE MINIMAL
TO SUPPORT THIS PART OF OUR.
OUR SOCIETY.
AND.
I THINK IT'S EMBARRASSING.
I AM VERY VERY THANKFUL THAT
WE'RE STARTING TO BECOME AWARE.
AND I HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU WILL
NOT JUST SAY THAT.
THE IS SUPPORT PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES BUT
THINK YOU'LL ACTUALLY EMBRACE
THEIR CHALLENGES BY SUPPORTING
THEM THROUGH FUNDS.
YOU NOTE THE FACT REMAINS AND I
WAS VERY DISCOURAGED TO FIND
THIS OUT WHEN I GOT ELECTED TO
THIS OFFICE.
THAT THERE ARE SO MANY WORTHY
CAUSES THAT WE ALL TRY TO
SUPPORT. AND THAT WE TRY TO DO
OUR BEST
TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
BUT THESE THESE FOLKS.
DON'T HAVE.
A BAND OF LOBBYISTS
BETTER. BEATING THEIR DRUM.
AND ALLOWING THEM TO COMPETE OUT
FAIR GROUND.
LET US.
REACH INTO OUR SOUL.
AND REALIZE WE HAVE A COMMITMENT
THERE IS NO PART OF OUR
POPULATION IS MORE WORTHY THAT
OF SUPPORT. IN THESE PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE CONDITIONS THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
AND WE HAVE THE DUTY TO EMBRACE
THEM. FOR THE GOOD PEOPLE THEY
ARE.
IN A PLATE FULL THAT THIS IS A
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION I.
ASK YOU SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AT
THE VERY MINIMUM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A MEMBER
SAW I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF.
HR EIGHTY NINE I APPLAUD MY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM OAKLEY IN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM. BY FROM PALM
DALES WELL THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND AS AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED.
THESE ARE.
OUR FRIENDS OUR NEIGHBORS OUR
CHILDREN.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT IS WE WE
SO OFTEN HOW.
WALK RIGHT BY WHEN WE SEE THEM
IN THE IN THE GROCERY STORE OUT
IN THE PARKS.
AND I TELL YOU.
I'M GUILTY OF THAT MYSELF
SOMETIMES.
BUT BUT I MAKE A CONCERTED
EFFORT.
TO SAY HELLO AND TO TALK TO THE
FAMILIES AND TALK TO THE PARENTS
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS AT
THAT. THAT IT'S HAPPENED FOR ME
IS I'VE BEEN UP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WORKING ON BEHALF OF
ISSUES LIKE THIS. IS I HAVE
EMBRACED ALONG WITH MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES OF THIS ISSUE. AND I
WILL CONTINUE TO BRACE THIS
EMBRACE THIS ISSUE MUCH LIKE OUR
FOSTER YOUTH THESE ARE OUR
CHILDREN THESE ARE OUR PARENTS
AND OUR FRIENDS AND. LIKE I SAID
OUR NEIGHBORS AND FAMILY.
AND WE OWE IT TO THEM.
TO BE COMPASSIONATE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR PRIORITIES
ARE MISPLACED.
THAT OUR PRIORITY IS ARE IT IS
WITH THOSE THAT CANNOT DO FOR
THEMSELVES AND I WILL CONTINUE
AS LONG AS I AM ABLE. AND AS
LONG AS I AM HERE AND LONG AFTER
TO CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR FOR
THOSE THAT FRANKLY CAN'T
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES
OFTENTIMES AND I'LL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT AND I APPLAUD MY
COLLEAGUES ARE AND AYES. A FULLY
SUPPORT HR EIGHTY NINE AND I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
DEBATER DISCUSSION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE MEASURE AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES PLEASE
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR STANDING UP AND
TALKING ABOUT THIS POPULATION.
YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES IF WE WERE
ALL TO DO WITH YOU LOOK AT WE
HAVE FIFTY BILLS WE CAN DO IN A
CYCLE IN A SESSION.
IF WE ALL EIGHTY OF US TOOK ONE
BILL.
CHANGE THE LIVES THESE WONDERFUL
PEOPLE. LOOK AT WHAT A
DIFFERENCE YOU WOULD MAKE.
THAT'S A COMMITMENT I'M LOOKING
FOR FROM MY COLLEAGUES THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY TAKE A ONE BILL.
AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND WORK
TOWARDS.
INCLUSION INTO THE COMMUNITY AND
SUPPORTING THEM.
MADAM SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER FRAZIER IS ASKING FOR THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
COOK WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS
ROSE FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS RULES RECALL AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE COOPER IS
ON THE RESOLUTION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ON THOSE IN
FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
MISTER CALDERON SKETCH A DESK
FOR YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
IF I CAN DIRECT OUR COLLEAGUES
ATTENTION TO THE GALLERY ABOUT.
THERE ARE LEADERS OF THE
COMMUNITY HERE WITH US TODAY THE
STATE COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
THE ARK.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY A SUPPLY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION. AND MY
FRIEND AUDRA IS HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING. A VOTE OF
CONFIDENCE YOU'RE FORWARD. FOR
OUR FRIENDS.
AND WE JUST WISH THAT WE COULD
STAND AND APPLAUD.
THESE FOLKS WERE ADVOCATING. FOR
THIS POPULATION OF OUR DD.
POPULATION THANK YOU
.
THANK YOU WILL BE BACK ON THE
PILE ORDER TO ITEM FOR.
SO MAY GO SIXTY NINETY FOUR BY
SO MEMBER MARK STONE THAT RELATE
FOSTER CLEAR IT BECAUSE DECLARED
ZERO SIX BACK IMMEDIATELY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FOR A THREE PASSED
OUT OF THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR.
AND IN THE CHAPTER GOT
AMENDMENTS WAS ONE. SEEMINGLY
MINOR AMENDMENT THAT TURNED OUT
TO BE A BIG DEAL AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT CHANGE THE
PRIORITIES OF HOW. WE FIND.
SLOTS FOR CHILD CARE WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS REPEAL THAT SECTION
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION.
WITHOUT THE INTERFERENCE OF THAT
LANGUAGE ABOUT CHILDCARE SLOTS
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DEBATER
DISCUSSION THE CLERK WILL PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ON TELLY
DEVOTES.
I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE AYE SIXTY ONE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED.
I AM FIFTEEN PASS TEMPORARILY.
ITEMS.
FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN WILL BE
CONTINUED.
I AM TWENTY PASS AND RETAIN ITEM
TWENTY ONE ACR ONE FIFTY THE
CLERK WILL PLEASE READ.
SO THE CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
FIFTY BY SOME WOMEN BELIEVE ALL
RELATIVE TO DUAL ENROLLMENT
WEEK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AMMONIA
RECOGNIZE THINK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. ACR ONE FIFTY
RECOGNIZES MARCH EIGHTEENTH
THROUGH MARCH TWENTY FOURTH AS
JUNE MOMENT WEEK IN CALIFORNIA.
DOING MOMENT PROGRAMS OFFER
PUPILS THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
INCOMPLETE CHALLENGING COLLEGE
COURSES WHILE STILL ENROLLED IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
PARTICIPATION AND DUAL
ENROLLMENT COURSES PREPARE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS FOR THE ACADEMIC
REQUIREMENTS OF COLLEGE. ENABLE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
COLLEGE LEVEL UNITS.
AT OF FREE AND DISCOUNTED RATE.
AND IT ALSO INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF A COLLEGE DEGREE
COMPLETION.
THIS ENABLES SUBSTANTIAL SAVINGS
IN COLLEGE AS WELL IS A PATHWAY
TO HIGHER EDUCATION FOR ALL
PEOPLES. ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
ACR ONE FIFTY RECOGNIZES DO ON
ROLE MAY AS A TOOL TO INCREASE
COLLEGE ACCESS AND DEGREE
ATTAINMENT FOR STUDENTS
TYPICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST
ROLE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
YES
OKAY MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE AUTHORS. MEMBERS THIS
ROLE WAS FOR COAL AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
MEMBERS IS ROSE RECALL AUTHORS.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THIS ITEM ALWAYS IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B.
TO OVER. OF THE CLERK WILL
PLEASE READ.
SO WE WROTE TWO THOUSAND FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE NOT
REALLY GOOD PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT FARAMIR XEROPHYTIC
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY SENATE EVER
OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER SEVERAL AGENCIES
WITH THE BIG BEAR VALLEY WITH IN
MY DISTRICT WISH TO CONSOLIDATE
FIRE PROTECTION WITHIN THE
VALLEY INTO A SINGLE NEW AGENCY
THE BIG BEAR FIRE AUTHORITY.
HOWEVER THEY BEEN HAMPERED IN
THIS EFFORT BY THE FACT THAT THE
MEMBER AGENCIES CURRENTLY USE
DIFFERENT RETIREMENT SYSTEMS.
THIS BILL AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR
WILL ALLOW PUBLIC SAFETY
EMPLOYEES TO BE TRANSFERRED TO
THE NEW AGENCY WITHOUT
TERMINATION LIABILITY TO THE
MEMBER AGENCIES. THIS SHOULD
RESULT IN THE PROVISION OF
HIGHER QUALITY FIRE PROTECTION
IN MY DISTRICT AT LOWER COST TO
TAXPAYERS AND I REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING THE VOTE SIXTY SIX I
KNOW ZERO ON THE MEASURE. SIXTY
SIX I KNOW ZERO ON THE URGENCY
OF THE.
THE MEASURE PASSED.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY THREE ACR
ONE NINETY FOUR MISTER QUICKLY
ST.
SOME A CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
MORE NINETY FOUR BY SOME THE
MEMORY IS RELATIVE TO WHAT YOU
KNOW EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY WE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A AS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU. ACR ONE NINE
FOUR WHICH DECLARES LAST WEEK OF
MARCH AS A STATEWIDE WEEK FOR
LATINO EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY.
TODAY LATINOS ARE THE LARGEST
MINORITY GROUP IN THE UNITED
STATES IN CALIFORNIA ALONE
LATINO STUDENTS MAKE UP OVER
HALF OF THE K. THROUGH TWELVE
ENROLLMENT.
DESPITE THE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
WHICH HAS BEEN MADE IN RECENT
YEARS LATINO STUDENTS STILL HAVE
AMONG THE HIGHEST HIGH SCHOOL
DROPOUT RATES.
HAVE LOWER SCORES ON ACHIEVEMENT
TESTS AND HAVE LOWER COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT RATES THAN THEIR
PEERS.
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND MANY
MORE WHICH THE ROUND THE LATINO
COMMUNITY. AND THEIR EDUCATION
BELIEVE ORGANIZATION AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY SAN
BERNARDINO.
HOUSES SEVERAL NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL PROJECTS.
ON MARCH TWENTY NINTH AT CSU
SANDRA DINO WILL HOST ITS NINTH
ANNUAL LATINO EDUCATION AND
ADVOCACY DAYS.
OR THE LEAD SOP SUMMIT
CELEBRATED UNDER THE DIRECTION
OF DR INDICATE MOODY YOUNG.
OVER ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE IN THE SUMMIT
ANNUALLY. WHILE STUPID IT IS
BROADCASTED TO SEVEN COUNTRIES
AND WATCHED BY MILLIONS.
THIS IS WHY TODAY I PRESENT TO
YOU ACR ONE NINE FOUR TO DECLARE
THE LAST WEEK OF MARCH. LATINO
EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY WEEK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
ANNOUNCED THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPENED FOR.
COAUTHORS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER THURMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE OWNS IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE NINETY FOUR.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR HER
AUTHORSHIP IN LEADERSHIP ON THIS
MEASURE.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT WEEK
AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY I'M
MINDFUL OF MANY ARE GREAT
LEADERS.
WHO ARE NOT THE YOU KNOW WHO
HAVE REASON TO BE LEADERS IN
EDUCATION AS SUPERINTENDENTS AS
PROFESSORS AS EDUCATORS AND AS
CHAMPIONS FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERSHIP? A NON PARDONED AND.
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE SONIA
SOTOMAYOR YOUR WHO WAS A
PROFESSOR AT HARVARD AND MANY OF
YOU HAVE EXPERIENCED THE
EDUCATION FOUNDATION IN THE
CIVIC FOUNDATION. STARTED BY OUR
CALIFORNIA'S OWN THE LOTUS WHEN
IT UP WE KNOW THAT THERE BEEN
MANY GREAT OPPORTUNITIES BUT YET
THERE ARE STILL. OPPORTUNITIES
TO FULFILL A GREAT EDUCATION FOR
ALL STUDENTS INCLUDING OUR
LATINO STUDENTS IN MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
BOTH OF THE LARGEST DISTRICTS IN
OUR ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ARE ARE
MORE THAN FIFTY PERCENT LATINO
STUDENTS AS YOU HEARD. WE
CONTINUE TO SEE AN ACHIEVEMENT
GAP FOR MANY STUDENTS INCLUDING
LATINO STUDENTS AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
FROM LOW INCOME BACKGROUNDS. LET
US TAKE THIS WEEK IN THIS
RECOGNITION AS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO EXPAND OUR EDUCATIONAL
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT LATINO
STUDENTS IN ALL STUDENTS IN THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR ACR ONE
NINETY FOUR LATINO EDUCATION AND
ADVOCACY WEEK.
THANK YOU SEEN OUR FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WE WILL
OPEN THE FIRST ROLE. AUTHORS.
MEMBERS IS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY THREE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MR CHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR INTRODUCTIONS.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES IT'S A
REAL PLEASURE FOR ME TO
INTRODUCE CHRISTIAN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL ALL WAY COMING FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS IN FOURTH
GRADE COMING TO THE CAPITAL
INMATE PROFOUND IMPACT ON ME IT
WAS A BIG REASON WHY I DECIDED
TO CRIME BECOME ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
HOPEFULLY PERHAPS ONE DAY ONE OF
YOU GUYS IN THE GALLERY AT
CHRISTIAN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CAN
COME UP TO BE SITTING ON THE
FLOOR TO AS A MEMBER OF THE
STATE ASSEMBLY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
WELCOME CHRISTIAN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL THAT CAPITAL.
THANK YOU MOVING BACK TO THE
DAILY FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR ACR
ONE NINETY NINE.
PLEASE READ SO MAKING CURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE NINETY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER CARILLO RELATIVE
TO ARCHBISHOP OSCAR ES ROMERO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE NINETY NINE. A
RESOLUTION COMMEMORATING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LATE ARCH
BISHOP OSCAR ROMERO OF ALL
SALVADORAN A THIRTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF HIS DEATH. AS
WELL AS THE CONNECTIONS HIS
LEGACY HAVE CREATED WITH ALL
SALVADORAN THE COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS RESOLUTION COMES TO THE
HEELS COMES ON THE HEELS OF THE
ASSEMBLY DELEGATION TO ALL
SALVADOR AND BUILDS ON OUR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT FOR
DIPLOMACY BETWEEN.
THE SALVADOREAN GOVERNMENT AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS BACKGROUND.
THE SALVADORAN CIVIL WAR BEGAN
IN EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
LASTED FOR TWELVE YEARS AND TOOK
THE LIVES OF APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND.
SALVADORANS
THIS VIOLENCE BY A GOVERNMENT
AGAINST IS PEOPLE THAT MANY
SALVADORANS INCLUDING MY FAMILY.
TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY. SEEK
SAFETY AND OTHER PLACES.
AND SEEK SOLUTIONS SUCH AS
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS WHICH
WE CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT. IN
THIS VERY MOMENT
SEEK ASYLUM BECOME REFUGEES. AND
SOME EVEN COME TO OTHER PLACES
THAT UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
ARCHBISHOP OSCAR ROMERO OF SAN
SALVADOR.
GROWS UP AS A RELUCTANT HERO
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THE CIVIL
WAR.
AND THE MANY AGREE JUST HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS WHICH WERE
OCCURRING AT THAT TIME. AND
WHICH LASTED FOR TWELVE YEARS.
INDIAN ARCHBISHOP ROMERO IS
ADVOCACY FOR THE POOR AND FOR
JUSTICE.
LED TO HIS EXECUTION AND
ASSASSINATION WHILE HE WAS
GIVING MASS.
ON MARCH TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN
EIGHTY.
SINCE THEN.
THE LATIN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
INCLUDING MANY CHURCH GROUPS.
SALVADORAN CATHOLICS REGARD
ROMERO AT AN OFFICE AS AN
UNOFFICIAL PATRON.
TO THE AMERICAS AND TO THEIR
COUNTRY.
MANY OTHER DENOMINATIONS HONOR
ARCHBISHOP ROMERO INCLUDING.
THE CHURCH OF ENGLAND.
AS THEY SALVADORAN AMERICAN I
CAN TELL YOU THIS ARCHBISHOP
ROMERO LEGACY OF PEACE CONTINUES
TO THIS DAY.
AND IT INSPIRES SALVADORIAN
EVERYWHERE TO LOOK FOR A MORE
JUST AND PROSPEROUS TOMORROW. IN
IT FAR EXCEEDS THE SALVADOREAN
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS ABOUT FAITH.
AND JUSTICE.
AND HOW SOMEBODY THAT WAS GIVING
MASS.
WAS TAKEN.
BECAUSE OF A PURSUIT TOWARDS
JUSTICE.
AND AGAINST THE WAR.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE CAN SEE
THE IMPROVEMENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
GROWING CULTURAL AND ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ALL
SALVADORAN.
WHICH THE SPEAKER MYSELF AND TWO
OTHER COLLEAGUES WITNESSED FIRST
HAND.
IN OUR ASSEMBLY DELEGATION TO
THE COUNTRY.
RECENTLY POPE FRANCIS IN
RECOGNITION OF OUR OF THE
ARCHBISHOP'S
SELFLESS DEVOTION A PEACE AND
JUSTICE HAS TAKEN THE FINAL
STEPS.
TOWERS THE CANONIZATION AND
SAINTHOOD OF OSCAR ROMERO.
THIS RESOLUTION PROCLAIMS MARCH
TWENTY FOUR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
AS A DAY OF REMEMBRANCE OF
ARCHBISHOP OSCAR ROMERO OF ALL
SALVADORAN CALIFORNIA. AND JOINS
THE CALIFORNIAN THE SALVADORAN
COMMUNITY AND CELEBRATING HIS
EXAMPLE OF SACRIFICE.
ON THE OCCASION OF THE THIRTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF HIS DEATH.
FURTHERMORE THIS RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZES.
THE UNIFYING HISTORY AND
CULTURAL CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND ALL SALVADORAN
BODY. IN THE LIFE AND WORK.
OF ARCHBISHOP ROMERO THINK YOU
AND I URGE YOU AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE LADY THE
GENTLE LADY FROM LOS ANGELES
WHO.
ONE REPRESENTS OUT SALVADORAN
COMMUNITY VERY WELL ON THE HAD A
PLEASURE OF TRAVELING SOUTH
SALVADOR WITH THE DELEGATION.
ACTUALLY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GO TO THE ARCHBISHOP GRAVELY A
SEARCH AND FIND OUT THAT HE.
IN HIS COUNTRY WAS THIS AS A
CHAVEZ HERE IN HIS COUNTRY WAS
THE MARS THE KING HE WAS THE
DRUM MAJOR FOR JUSTICE. AND ALSO
HAD A DISTINCT OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE LUNCH WITH HIS NEPHEW WHO
HIS FAMILY STILL HAVE TO.
LIVE UNDER COVER BECAUSE OF
THREATS OF THEIR LIVES.
THIS MAN HAS DONE A TREMENDOUS
JOB WITHOUT STARVING DORY
COMMUNITY FOR THE COUNTRY AND
CERTAINLY THINK ITEMS INSPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT. ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS PLEASE FOR AYE VOTE
ON ACR ONE NINETY NINE I THINK
THE GENTLEWOMAN FROM LOS ANGELES
FOR BRINGING THIS.
TO THIS FLOOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I WANTED TO SHARE WITH OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM LOS ANGELES
A MEMORY THAT WE HAD TOGETHER.
BECAUSE WE WENT TO THE CUT THE
THE WRONG METROPOLIT BOMBING.
WHICH IS THE BEARING SPOT FOR
OSCAR THEIR CRIMINAL.
AND HE IS MEMORIALIZED WITH
SOMETHING OVER HIS TOMB WHICH
SAYS SEND ID ONE LOG LAST YEAR.
TO FEEL FOR THE CHURCH.
AN OSCAR THEIR ROOM MEADOW IS
SUMMARIZED IN MY MIND AS LAW
MOST THEIR LOSS SEEMED BOSS.
THE VOICE FOR THE VOICELESS.
IT WAS POWERFUL.
TO BE IN EL SALVADOR AND TO FEEL
THE PASSION THAT THE PEOPLE HAD
FOR THIS TRUE LEADER FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND I'M HONORED TO
SUPPORT ACR ONE NINETY NINE AND
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION A
DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE A WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THIS
ITEM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MANY OF US COME FROM.
VARIOUS DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE WORLD.
AND HAVE A HISTORY.
OF JUSTICE.
IN A FIGHT FOR OPPORTUNITY AND
EQUALITY SOMETHING THAT I TALK
ABOUT ALL THE TIME.
WHEN I FIRST GOT HERE I BROUGHT
MY PARENTS WITH US WITH ME.
AND I'VE BEEN SHARING.
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE BEEN AND
UNRECOGNIZED REFUGEE THAT FLOOD?
THE CIVIL WAR IN EL SALVADOR.
MANY OF US LOOK TO THIS BODY.
TO RECOGNIZE THE RECOGNITIONS
OF.
THOUSANDS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO TALK.
ABOUT THE SALVADORAN COMMUNITY
AND TPS IMMIGRATION.
AND KNOW THAT ARCHBISHOP ROMERO.
GAVE HIS LIFE FOR HIS LIFE WAS
TAKEN AWAY WHILE HE GAVE MASS.
HE WAS ASSASSINATED.
AND WHILE IT'S BEEN SEVERAL
DECADES SINCE SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THIS IS A MOMENT FOR THIS
BODY TO RECOGNIZE.
BUT THIS MOVEMENT IS SEEN AROUND
THE WORLD.
AND THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY.
TO ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
EVERYONE THE CALLS.
THIS STATE HOME.
FEEL SAFE AND SECURE.
AND THAT THIS RECOGNITION FOR
ARCHBISHOP ROMERO.
IT'S A TESTAMENT
TO THEIR LIVES.
WHAT THEY'VE GONE THROUGH?
AND WHAT WE CAN DO WITH THE
STATE TO CONTINUE OUR DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE COUNTRY.
ASK.
VOTE THANK YOU.
WE DO LIKE THE FIRST ROLE TO BE
OPEN FOR COOPERS.
YES PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CLARK WAS OPEN.
BOTH WERE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS ROLES FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THEY ARE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE ITEM ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
I AM TWENTY FIVE PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY SIX HR
EIGHTY SEVEN MISTER COURT PLEASE
READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SOME REMEMBER CHIU RELATIVE TO
ARTS EDUCATION LAW.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS HRT EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD
DECLARE MARCH EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. S. ART EDUCATION MONTH
TO RECOGNIZE THREE IMPORTANCE
ROLE OF ART PLATES BEING
PROMOTING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
CULTURAL UNDERSTANDING.
READ IN THOSE FOR LEARNING
CREATIVITY'S AND EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
ARTS EDUCATION WHICH INCLUDE
DANCE MUSIC THEATER. AND VISUAL
ARTS IS RECOGNIZED AS PART OF
THE.
OF. QUALITY K. TO TWELVE
EDUCATION BY THE EDUCATION CODE.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
ADMISSION POLICIES.
DISRUPTING RESOLUTION WILL URGE
ALL ELECTED OFFICIALS TO
PARTICIPATE WITH THEIR COMING
COMMUNITIES IN CELEBRATING THE
ART.
THE HR A.
THE HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
WOULD LIKE TO HELP THE FIRST ROW
OPEN VOCAL AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DEBATER
DISCUSSION MISTER CLICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE OFFERS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLES FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS
ON THE MEASURE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN ACR ONE
SEVENTY FIVE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ SOME OF YOUR CURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER RUBIO AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO ENDOMETRIOSIS
AWARENESS MONTH.
THANK YOU AT SOME EVER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM. MADAM SPEAKER I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD DECLARE
THE MONTH OF MARCH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OF ANTI INDOOR
MATERIALS IS AWARENESS MONTH.
AND THE MATERIALS IS OF THE
DISEASE WITH NO KNOWN CURE.
OR BECAUSE IN WHICH TISSUE THAT
NORMALLY GROWS IN THE UTERUS
BEGINS TO GROW OUTSIDE OF THE
UTERUS LEADING TO CHRONIC
DEBILITATING PAIN.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT GREATER
AWARENESS WILL LEAD WOMEN TO
EARLY DIAGNOSIS BETTER TREATMENT
AND A BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE.
MEMBERS I CAN ALMOST GUARANTEE
THAT EACH AND EVERYONE OF US IN
THIS CHAMBER EITHER HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER FRIEND OR
COLLEAGUE. THAT IS SUFFERING
FROM THE TERRIBLE CONDITION.
ENDOMETRIOSIS AFFECTS AT LEAST
ONE IN TEN WOMEN. OF REPEAT
REPRODUCTIVE AGE.
WHAT'S MORE ON AVERAGE WOMEN
SUFFER FOR TEN YEARS BETWEEN THE
FIRST SYMPTOMS OF PAIN AND THE
FINAL ENDOMETRIOSIS DIAGNOSES.
THIS.
THIS DISEASE CAN AFFECT EVERY
ORGAN OF THE BODY AND FREQUENTLY
LEADS TO LOWER QUALITY OF LIFE.
SCHOOL AND WORK ABSENCES
INFERTILITY AND UNNECESSARY HIGH
MEDICAL COSTS.
ACCORDING TO STUDIES THIS
PAINFUL DISORDER CAUSES WOMEN TO
MESS ON AVERAGE TEN HOURS OF
WORK PER WEEK.
AS AN OVERALL COST OF A HUNDRED
IN NINETEEN BILLION IN LOST
WORKPLACE PRODUCTIVITY.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME AND HELP
RAISE AWARENESS OF ENDOMETRIOSIS
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT THIS COMING WEEKEND ON
MARCH TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. SAN FRANCISCO ALONG
WITH SIXTY THREE COUNT COUNTIES
I'M SORRY COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD WILL PARTICIPATE IN THE
WORLDWIDE ENDOMETRIOSIS MARCH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I WOULD LIKE THE FIRST
ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE. OFFICE.
MEMBERS THIS RULE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS ITEM. ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO
YOUR RECOGNIZE FEAR GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE TO THE BODY SARAH
MCLELLAN SARA'S ARE ASSEMBLY
CHIEF SERGEANTS WIFE AND AFTER
SEVENTEEN YEARS OF PEOPLE
SUFFERING WAS JUST RECENTLY
DIAGNOSED. WITH ENDOMETRIOSIS
DURING AN UNRELATED SURGERY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AND
WE WE WISH YOU A FULL RECOVERY.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND.
ACKNOWLEDGING SARAH MCCLENDON.
THANK YOU ITEMS TWENTY THROUGH
THIRTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING BACK.
I'M SORRY MISS RUBY ARE YOU. ARE
YOU. ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
A MEMBER OF MY STAFF SARAB DOOR
WHO IS WATCHING THIS FLOOR
SESSION FROM MY DISTRICT OFFICE
SHE TWO SUFFERED AND WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH ENDOMETRIOSIS.
I'D LIKE TO WISH HER A SPEEDY
RECOVERY AND THAT HER NO THAT
WE'RE ALL THINKING EVER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ITEMS TWENTY THROUGH THIRTY ONE
PASS AND RETAIN RETURNING TO
ITEM FIFTEEN AB FOUR ONE SEVEN
MISTER QUICKLY THREE.
SOME AGO FOR SEVENTEEN BY SO
MEMORABLY MOAN AND OTHERS ARE
NOT RELATED HEALTH FACILITIES IN
THE CLARITY OF EUROPE THAT
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
PASS TEMPORARILY UP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE MON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER.
AB FOR SEVENTEENTH IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMONG THOSE
STRUCTURES BURNED BY THE THOMAS
FIRE. WHICH TWO BUILDINGS AT
AURORA VISTA DEL MAR AN ACUTE
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL LOCATED IN
MY DISTRICT.
VISTA DEL MAR IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PROVIDER OF INPATIENT
AND OUTPATIENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WITHIN THE REGION.
AB FOR SEVENTEEN IS A VERY
NARROWLY CRAFTED LEGISLATION
THAT ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
AUTHORIZED OUT PATIENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. WHILE THE
HOSPITAL INPATIENT SERVICES ARE
SUSPENDED BECAUSE OF THE FIRE
DAMAGE.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
CDP AIDS AGENCY AND STE
STAKEHOLDERS TO CRAFT THIS
NARROW SOLUTION THIS BILL HAS
REALLY RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN POOR AND HAS NO.
OPPOSITION.
I ASKS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DEBATER
DISCUSSION MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOW MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE?
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
SIXTY FIVE TWO ZERO AND THE
URGENCY SIXTY FIVE TO ZERO ON
THE ITEM.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED.
MOVING BACK A SECOND READING
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SO MIDDLE TWENTY ONE OH FIVE
NINETEEN OH EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
TWENTY TO FORTY THREE TO.
TWENTY ONE NINETY SEVEN TWENTY
THE FORTY NINE TWENTY ONCE EVERY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY ONE
SIXTY NINE WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY WITH A MINUTES.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE WITH A
MINUTES AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE THIRTY THREE WITH A MENACE.
THANK YOU ALL BILLS HAVE A
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOVING OUT TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CAL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND THEY
CONSENT CALENDAR SO WE WILL
TWENTY SEVENTY SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN ACCOLADE
COUNTY EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT.
I THINK YOU THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ON THE CONCERT.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTES SIXTY SIX I
KNOW OPPOSE. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY
FIVE.
I SIXTY SIX KNOWS NONE SO MUCH
CONCURRENT HOOSIER ONE FORTY
NINE. I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE THREE BEFORE I SIX
IT'S NO ZERO SUM A GROOMER
SOLUTION ONE SIXTY NINE AYE
SIXTY
X. NO ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE EIGHTY NINE. I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO AND HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY ONE.
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER GALLAGHER FOR HIS GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
I THINK THE ONLY FOR YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF SEVERAL GUESTS ME
TODAY TO CELEBRATE GRAND JURY
AWARENESS MONTH ACR WHEN HE NINE
WAS PASSED ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY.
DURING THIS MONTH TO RECOGNIZE
THE DEDICATION AND HARDWORK OF
VOLUNTEERS WHO EXERCISE THEIR
VITAL FUNCTION OF OVERSEEING
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THE CIVIL
FUNCTIONS OF GRAND JURIES. OFF
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE
STATE IMPANELED GRAND JURIES TO
REPORT ON CIVIL MATTERS
INCLUDING THE OPERATIONS
ACCOUNTS AND RECORDS OF THE
OFFICERS.
DEPARTMENTS AND FUNCTIONS OF A
COUNTY. THESE REPORT SHED LIGHT
ON ACTIVITIES A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RECOMMENDING BEST
PRACTICES DISCOVERING
INEFFICIENCIES IN ASSISTING
PUBLIC OFFICIALS IN PROVIDING
QUALITY SERVICES. TO ALL. AS A
FORMER CENTER COUNTY SUPERVISOR
I CAN ATTEST FIRST TOWN. FIRST
TEND TO THE INVALUABLE NATURE OF
THESE REPORTS.
I FOR EXAMPLE JUST LAST YEAR IN
TEHAMA COUNTY THE GRAND JURY
REPORT RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HELP
INCREASE COLLABORATION BETWEEN
PRIVATE PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
ORGANIZATIONS. TO PROVIDE BETTER
SERVICES FOR THE FOR HOMELESS IN
THE CITY OF RED BLUFF.
ARE THESE HONORABLE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
DESERVING OF RECOMMENDATION.
AND WE HAVE WITH US TODAY ASSN
MEMBERS A GRAND JURY IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SUTTER COUNTY
GRAND YEARS ASSOCIATION OF BECKY
JENNINGS.
STEVE MYERS VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE SUTTER COUNTY GRAND JURIES
ASSOCIATION. GARY SPA FROM THE
SAN JOAQUIN. COUNTY GRAND JURIES
ASSOCIATION AND HOUSE ARE ALSO
SEVERAL OTHER GRAND JURORS WHO
ARE SERVING ACROSS THE STATE.
PLEASE WELCOME THEM MEMBERS AND
GIVE THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
THANK YOU SENATOR READING ITEM
THIRTY TWO.
MEMBERS SPRING RECESS BEGINS ON
POT ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION TODAY
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH TWENTY
THIRD RECESS.
AND THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED AND WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON THE GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
ARE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR LET'S GIVE OUR RESPECT
TO THOSE MEMBERS WITH THE
GERMANS AND MEMORIES.
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO*
BODY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
THE HONORABLE FORMER MAYOR. OF
COMPTON DOORS DAVIS DOORS DAVIS
WAS BORN. IN MOUNT VERNON
GEORGIA. IN NINETEEN THIRTY
THROUGH NINETEEN THIRTY ONE.
WHERE SHE GREW UP IN CHICAGO?
ILLINOIS.
SHE ATTENDED NORTHWESTERN
UNIVERSITY RECEIVED HER MASTER'S
DEGREE IN EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATION.
BEFORE GETTING MARRIED.
TO CEDRIC  DAVIS.
THEY MOVE TO LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA.
AFTER MOVING.
SHE SERVED AS A TEACHER IN THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND TOPS
FROM NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE.
AND THIS IN TURN TO POLITICS.
BEATING A TWENTY EIGHT YEAR
INCUMBENT BECOMING THE FIRST.
AFRICAN AMERICAN CLERK.
OF THE METROPOLITAN
CITY IN AMERICA.
THE VICTORY SERVE AS A PLATFORM.
WHICH SHE LATER WAS ELECTED AS
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN
TO HOLD. OFFICE
MAKING HER THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
MAYOR.
OF A METROPOLITAN AMERICAN CITY.
SHE SERVED.
THE CITY OF COMPTON.
FAITHFULLY.
SHE ONCE SAID.
THERE IS MUCH TO POLITICS THE
INFLUENCE.
AND MAKE CITIES BETTER.
AND GREAT
BY USING THIS OFFICE
TO MAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES BETTER.
MS DAVIS BELONG TO A NUMBER OF.
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE NWC
PAY.
THE URBAN LEAGUE AND THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS.
SHE FOUNDED THE DAISY CHILD
DEVELOPMENT CENTER NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN.
TO PROVIDE WAY WERE TEEN MOTHERS
AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO GIVE THEM.
A FOUNDATION AND STRUCTURE IN
LIFE.
MS DAVIS.
LEAVES.
TO CHERISH HER MEMORY.
HER SON.
CEDRIC OMAR DAVIS A THIRD.
JOHN KENNY DAVIS.
A HOST OF GRANDCHILDREN.
SHE WILL BE MISSED
BY MANY.
AS ONE WHO HAS CERTAINLY
CHERISHED.
CITY OF COMPTON.
THEN IMAGES ALSO SAY THIS.
THAT HER BODY LIE AGAINST IN IN
THE CITY COUNCIL CHAMBERS.
AND SO MANY PEOPLE CAME TO PAY
TRIBUTE A REFERENCE TO HER GREAT
LEGACY.
AS THE FIRST FEMALE MAYOR OF A
METROPOLITAN CITY IN THE IN
AMERICA AND ALSO A GREAT LEADER.
AND I'M REMINDED OF A STORY THAT
WAS MADE MENTION OF DURING OUR
SERVICE.
ABOUT HER FAITHFULNESS KNOWN AS
A GUY BUT ALSO TO OUR BIBLE
STUDY MEMBERS PLEASE ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY. OF THE ARTICLE DORIS
DAVIS.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF GONZALEZ
FLETCHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ASSN WE GERMAN
THE MEMORY OF JOAQUIN ARAMBULA
WHO FORMERLY LED THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE AND
EDUCATION FUND. IT WAS THE
ARCHITECT OF THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA WAS BORN ON
JUNE TWENTY THIRD NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT AND LOS ANGELES TO MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS
HE GREW UP IN COMPTON.
DESPITE FACING ADVERSITIES AS A
CHILD HE WENT ON TO BECOME A
HIGH HIS HIGH SCHOOL'S
VALEDICTORIAN.
ATTENDED YELLING GRADUATED FROM
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL.
FOLLOWING HIS GRADUATION FROM
LAW SCHOOL MISTER ABBEY LA JOIN
NOW DEAF WE WORKED ON NUMEROUS
SUPPORT CASES TO EXPAND SOMEONE
VOTING RIGHTS OF LATINOS.
THREAT HIS LONG DISTINGUISHED
CAREER IS AN ATTORNEY HE WAS
INVOLVED IN MORE THAN SEVENTY
VOTING RIGHTS AND EQUAL
REPRESENTATION CASES INCLUDING
TWO ARGUED BEFORE THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT.
IN HIS FIRST SUPREME COURT.
PRIOR VETO.
THE COURT HELD THAT STATES
CANNOT CONSTITUTIONALLY DENY
STUDENTS A FREE PUBLIC EDUCATION
ON ACCOUNT OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
IN HIS SECOND CASE LOPEZ BE
BECOMING A MODERATE COUNTY. THE
COURT SIDED WITH MISTER AVILA
THAT THE MODERATE COUNTIES
CONSOLIDATION OF COURT DISTRICTS
INTO A SINGLE COUNTY WIDE
MUNICIPAL DISTRICT VIOLATED
VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
ESSENTIALLY JUST IN FRANCHISING
LATINO VOTERS.
HAS HE DONE ALL ITS LIFE MISTER
HOBBY LA PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN
ESTABLISHING THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE TO ENSURE FAIR AND
EQUAL REPRESENTATION THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE.
MOST RECENTLY MISTER IV THAT WAS
A DIRECTOR THE NATIONAL VOTING
RIGHTS ADVOCACY INS INITIATIVE.
AT SEATTLE UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
LAW.
ON MARCH NINTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
HE PASSED AWAY DUE TO
COMPLICATIONS WITH CANCER.
MISTER AVILA IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF NEARLY FIFTY YEARS
DAHLE.
THEIR THREE CHILDREN JOAQUIN
JUNIOR SALVADOR IN ANGELIQUE A
BROTHER AND FOUR GRANDCHILDREN.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO CAUCUS AYE ASKS THAT YOU
JOIN ME ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY
OF JOAQUIN NABILA.
THANK YOU A SOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS FOR THE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF MY CONSTITUENTS JACQUI
RESEDA. IS JACK LAMBERT SAID I
WAS BORN ON AUGUST TWENTY THIRD
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND WAS A
LIFELONG RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
OUR WINDOW IN MY DISTRICT.
JACQUELINE TRULY LOVED HER
HOMETOWN AND WAS VERY INVOLVED
IN THE COMMUNITY.
SHE INSTILLED A PASSION FOR
SERVICE TO OTHERS
THIS PASSION WAS SEEN IN HER
COMMITMENT TO THE IRWIN DAHLE
SISTER CITY ORGANIZATION. MISS
CRISTATA SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF
THE ORGANIZATION FOR MANY YEARS
AND ALSO THE GROUP'S TREASURER.
DURING HER TENURE THE CLUB
CONTINUED AND EXPANDED THEIR
CULTURAL EXCHANGE WITH.
WINDOWS SISTER CITY OF SUN BUT
THE EVER WANNA Y. DON'T IN
MEXICO.
SHE ORGANIZED MANY SUPPORT
PROJECTS FOR THE BUT FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE RESIDENCE HALLS
FIVE UP YET ON.
HER DEDICATION TO HELPING OTHERS
WAS ALSO EVIDENT IN HER CAREER
IN BANKING.
THIS PROCEED A DEDICATED OVER
THIRTY YEARS TO THE BANKING
INDUSTRY. WORKING FOR LARGE AND
SMALL BANKING INSTITUTIONS SUCH
AS WASHINGTON MUTUAL AND CHASE
BANK.
THROUGH DEBT DILIGENCE AND
DETERMINATION SHE WORKED HER WAY
UP THROUGH THE POSITION OF
TELLER BANKER AND BRANCH
MANAGER.
HER EXPERTISE WAS CALLED UPON TO
OPENING NEW. A BRANCH AND GET
THEM UP AND RUNNING.
SHE WAS COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
THE SAME LEVEL OF BANKING
SERVICES TO HER CLIENTS IN THE
SMALLEST BRANCHES AS TO THOSE IN
THE LARGEST.
AT ONE POINT IN HER CAREER MISS
PRESENT A MANAGED ONE OF THE
LARGEST BANKING BRANCHES FOR
WASHINGTON MUTUAL ON THE WEST
COAST.
THE PROCEED A FAMILY WAS ALSO
COMMITTED TO CIVIC SERVICE
MISPERCEIVED US FATHER AND UNCLE
SERVED IN THE ON THE IRWIN DEL
CITY COUNCIL. AND SHE FOLLOWED
THEIR EXAMPLE.
JACKIE WAS ELECTED TO THE CITY
COUNCIL IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO
AND SERVED THROUGH NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN. HOLDING THE
POSITION OF MAYOR PRO PRO TEM
FROM NINETEEN NINETY FOUR TO
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE.
SHE ALSO INSPIRED HER BROTHER
MARK TO RUN AND SERVE ON THE
IRWIN DEL CITY COUNCIL.
TODAY MARK IS THE MAYOR AND HAS
BEEN THE LONGEST SERVING MAYOR
IN OUR WINDOW NOW ON HIS IS HIS
FIFTH TERM.
ENSURING THAT THE PERCENT OF
FAMILIES DEDICATION TO SERVICE
TO THEIR COMMUNITY CONTINUES FOR
YEARS TO COME.
MISS PER SE THAT LEFT US TOO
SOON ON FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
SHE IS PRECEDED BY HER BELOVED
PARENTS STELLAR AND RICHARD
PROCEED UP AND IS SURVIVED BY
HER BROTHERS RICHARD RECEITA AND
MAYOR MARK PROCEED OUT. OF HER
WINDOW MISPERCEIVED AS CARING
AND SERVICE TOUCHED MANY LIVES
HER LIFELONG FRIENDS AND FAMILY
IN.
WINDOW WHERE'D YOU WILL THIRTY
MEANS JACQUI THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES TO THE DUST REPRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO
ATTORNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
OTHER ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL
MOTIONS WILL BE CONTINUED
PURSUANT TO THE JOINT RULES THE
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED FOR
SPRING RECESS AND WE'LL
RECONVENE ON MONDAY APRIL SECOND
AT ONE PM